ein schreibmaschinen wettbewerb in den
30er jahren diese kriterien namens
astrid lindgren hat nicht nur flinke
hände sondern auch einen hellwachen
geist noch ahnt sie nicht dass sie
einmal die autorin der pippi langstrumpf
werden wird noch ist sie vor allem
hausfrau und mutter und führt mit ihrer
familie ein komfortables leben in
stockholm
am ersten september 19 39 trifft sie der
schock wie alle im neutralen schweden
heute hat der krieg begonnen
niemand wollte es glauben gestern
nachmittag saßen wm park die kinder
spielten und wir schimpfen ganz
gemütlich auf hitler und waren uns einig
dass es wohl keinen krieg geben würde
und dann das
so lautet der erste eintrag in den
kriegstagebüchern portiert und klug sind
sie geschrieben
privates ist immer eingebettet in den
großen zusammenhang
ein zeitdokument das einen anderen blick
auf astrid lindgren erlaubt tochter
karin war bei kriegsbeginn fünf jahre
alt sie war eine junge mutter deren
interesse an dem was in der welt geschah
größer war als das der meisten ihrer
landsleute
sie war sehr gut informiert und sie
holte sich ihre informationen aus den
zeitungen
aber nicht nur denn astrid lindgren hat
während des krieges eine stelle über die
sie nicht sprechen darf
sie arbeitet in der brief zensur des
schwedischen nachrichtendienstes und
erfährt aus den briefen die durch ihre
hände gehen von kriegsgräueln
deportationen und judenverfolgung
erschüttert tipp sie manche ab und nimmt
sie mit nach hause
obwohl das streng verboten ist
schweden ist wie die schweiz eine
neutrale insel
hier genießt man die sonne während
jenseits der grenze die welt
zusammenbricht
die gefühle im land sind zwiespältig
neben dankbarkeit herrscht angst vor dem
schlimmsten
schade dass niemand diesen hitler
erschießt so notiert astrid lindgren an
einer stelle ich war so wütend auf den
nationalsozialismus
dieses gefühl das war meine erste starke
politische engagement vor ihren kindern
verbirgt sie angst und wut
meine kindheit war glücklich weil ich
eine solche mutter hatte aber es war
keine glückliche zeit damals
obwohl wir glückliche zeit miteinander
hatten wir konnten weihnachten genießen
wir waren extrem privilegiert auch diese
weihnachten hatten wir kerzen
obwohl uns nur zehn stück zugeteilt
worden
und an essen mangelt es uns nicht weiter
sinken leberpastete braten geräucherte
aale ein stück näher rücken
draußen in der welt nichts als elend
für die deutschen sieht es schlecht aus
in russland und afrika das muss wohl der
anfang vom ende sein
ab 1944 werden die einträge kürzer etwas
neues beansprucht astrid lindgren zeit
sie schreibt die gute-nacht-geschichten
nieder die sie seit geraumer zeit ihrer
tochter erzählt und die von einem
ungewöhnlichen mädchen handeln mit pippi
langstrumpf amüsiere ich mich mächtig
anfangs glaubt astrid lindgren selbst
nicht an den erfolg
auch findet sie keinen verleger zu stark
zur anarchie ist diese pea
sie verkörpert eine kindheit die krieg
besonders erstrebenswert erscheint
pippi langstrumpf war glücklich und wild
und sie war nicht auf erwachsene
angewiesen
die erwachsenen hatten ja während des
krieges gezeigt dass man ihnen nicht
vertrauen konnte der krieg ist aus der
krieg ist die astrid lindgren ist ganz
schweden im freudentaumel 1945 schreibt
noch über die atombomben und den beginn
der nürnberger prozessen ende jahr
schliesst sie ihr tagebuch ab nun
beginnt der siegeszug durch die
kinderzimmer pippi langstrumpf trägt
eine botschaft von astrid lindgren in
die welt hinaus die auch in den
kriegserfahrungen wurzelt nichts ist
wichtiger für ein kind als freiheit und
geborgenheit